alors maintenant on va faire un hardi
view oui on a redit view alors l'étape
alors pas bougé pendant le jingle
bien vous faites bien ça tout ça c'est
un point de vue la garde devant mich
c'est un truc vous fait vachement bien
s'amuser alors c'est très simple vous
pensez à quoi là par exemple comment
vont trouver physiquement j'ai moi même
mais plutôt plutôt ça va oui c'est vrai
mais pas l'antenne par l'antenne kane et
dernière chose que vous faites avant de
vous coucher
jeffrey lexomil moi c'est pas très
original mais quoi j'ai pas vous dire
que ça fait quoi
ça fait quoi un lexomil sa kansas et
empêchent de se réveiller au milieu de
la nuit ont traversé orthez pas mal bon
sens - ben ouais milano je rentre oui
donc j'ai pas arrêté de dormir
définitivement gorge et le matin quand
vous voyez dans la glace vous vous dites
quoi par exemple la première chose
coulisses quand vous voyez comme ça que
je rende hormis quand vous étiez petit
bout là semble acquis un peu à claude
françois
je sais pas je n'ai pas trop ma tronche
il y en a qui on dirait on comprend non
je voulais jouer à être quelqu'un de
jouer quelqu'un d'autre voilà c'était ça
la maturité c'est plus ça va moi j'ai
envie d'être quelqu'un d'autre vous
accepter ça y est voilà je commence à un
an toutes leurs chances vous acceptiez
commencer par vous acceptez vous
finalement bal avec d'abord les autres
vous accès voilà je m'emmerde en
psychanalyse a oui ou par des pierres
tombales la peur alors quelle est la
phrase que vous ne supportez pas
d'entendre
je suis bien avec toi parce que j'en ai
marre des mecs bot entendus ça quand
j'étais adolescent ça m'avait choqué et
vie non qu'est ce que je n'aime pas
entendre si bien et toi parce que j'aime
les mecs qui me font rire oui oui mais
c'est pas incompatible j'ai l'impression
que quand on fait un compliment c'est
pour dire que non je te vois
est-ce que je suis représentant donc non
pour l'instant ça va aller on me dit
rien de désagréable ce qui vous énerve
le plus en vous non je suis peut-être un
peu des phrases telles un peu désinvolte
avec avec des gens qui m'aiment bien et
des fois comme je trouve que c'est
acquis je vais plutôt à la conquête des
gens qui m'aiment pas encore et je
deviens voilà je vous ai déjà cm du mans
le maître du monde c'est dieu lui un
sentiment de puissance absolue
ça fait ça quand on est sur scène ouais
quand on la cherchait nous quand on fait
très très lié à l'amour ça fait un peu
ça elle jouait déjà senti une [ __ ]
façon quand on a une sous merde vous
dirai pas quand ou avec keith d'accord
comment aimeriez-vous mourir assez
rapidement j'aimerais bien qu'on
commence à chiner pendant mon sommeil
parce que la sortie mais ça fait des
années que je me sens plus sentir
meanwhile the thing alors si c'était à
refaire votre vie qu'est-ce que vous ne
feriez pas du tout pareil
je crois que foutu comme je suis je
referais tout parce que même quand même
si vous savez moi j'irai dans les mêmes
murs presque aller dans un mur on a une
bosse pendant quelques temps et puis
après ça pèse 500 dur si vous pensez non
alors marque donc la cnae diéma trouve
que c'est je crois pas aux claques qui
vous aide dans la vie ouais non parce
qu'au bout d'un moment on est un peu
sonnés après on recommence en neuf jeux
est incorrigible
ouais ouais ben on allume la lumière
merci